yeah Mar stands accused of one of the
world's worst crimes the genocide of its
own people the case was brought by the
Gambia on behalf of dozens of Muslim
countries there are injured people
remain at serious risk of genocide on
Thursday the UN's highest court agreed
to deal with the case it also
unanimously agreed to impose an
emergency order to prevent more violence
the ruling compels Myanmar's forces to
end all acts of genocide or violence
including murder rape the burning of
villages the prevention of access to
medicine myanmar must also preserve all
evidence ahead of a very complicated
genocide trial the judgments binding and
cannot be appealed Myanmar must prove
its following the order reporting back
to the court in four months time and
every six months after the court has
ordered these periodic reports and that
is definitely a way for it to continue
to get information on what's happening
on the ground on another order that they
that they issued was to the preservation
of evidence so that in the future if
they were say individual prosecutions um
that could still happen but indeed they
want to see every six months what is
happening how are you in compliance with
this order so that they don't lose track
of what's going on the decision comes
despite a personal intervention from
Myanmar civilian leader Aung San su Chi
the Nobel Peace Prize laureate appeared
at the court in person last month where
she asked for the case to be dropped
near my requests accord to remove the
case from its list
she also denied genocide has been
committed and accused refugees of
exaggerating abuses Myanmar says the
raids on Ranga villages in Rakhine State
in 2017
were legitimate counterterrorism
operations around three-quarters of a
million of the Muslim minority fled to
neighboring Bangladesh during the
military offensive against them three
years ago The Gambia believes Myanmar
was and is trying to wipe out an entire
ethnic group all seventeen Jews from the
different parts of the world who are
present in different cultures and values
have all
that genocide cannot be tolerated by
anyone in the world and that the hunger
in me and my need protection our top
priority is justice today that justice
is partially soft this is a great day
for us we will celebrate it took the ICJ
more than a decade to reach a verdict of
genocide following the Balkan wars in
the 1990s
it's expected to be many years before
Myanmar faces a similar judgment Nev
Parker al Jazeera The Hague tava
Chaudhary is in Cox's Bazaar in
Bangladesh where he's been with a group
of her Hindu refugees as they listen to
this decision the ruling by the
International Court of Justice is very
much welcomed by the Rohingya refugee
communities here now we've been
discussing with many of the people after
the ruling sitting here in a feast all
they've been waiting here for hours
wanting to know what will be the outcome
they've been listening to it transistor
radio listening to various news and
they're discussing among themselves now
we talk to them see what their reaction
is they said it is very welcoming
they're very happy and anxious listen to
some of the reaction thanks to Allah for
this verdict and gambia for initiating
the legal process also thanks to
Bangladesh for giving a shelter
finally the verdict recognised are
suffering in all the atrocities we went
through we feel at peace in our hearts
we've been suffering for the last 70
years and we're seeking justice now we
truly believe that the world has
recognized our suffering from flex
detail of legal matters what they know
that ruling was in favor of the Rohingya
refugees and the Rohingya community in
life now they know this is symbolic that
may not something happened very quickly
we don't know yet whether the Myanmar
will accept this verdict whether other
countries will not put sanction and
pressure on Myanmar what the ringers
know that they've been recognized that
crime has been committed
they've been telling the whole world for
last several years that atrocities been
committed against us now they have been
recognized it's a very symbolic it's a
moral and a psychological victory for
them as to what they told me